life after what many hope
is the last lockdown with scenes like
this in london over the weekend
you'd be forgiven for thinking
restrictions were already over
infection rates are falling quickly
across the country with an 80
drop in infections in the capital cases
of the south african variant are also
shrinking
and with more than 17 million britons
receiving at least one dose of a covid19
vaccine
the government's now confident it can
offer every adult in the country
an injection by the end of july but when
it comes to easing restrictions
it's being cautious there are there are
signs that the numbers in hospital
are falling much more sharply than they
were in the first wave
and there's further analysis to be done
on that
but clearly the level is still far too
high that's why
the prime minister will be setting out a
road map we can't lift
the measures right now but we can
see that direction of travel the
government says it will determine
when to ease restrictions based upon
hard data
not upon pressure to set firm dates it
knows all too well
that by lifting restrictions too soon it
could well lead to a surge in infections
by leaving things too late the many
businesses that have been shattered for
months
could continue to suffer care home
residents have already been told they'll
be allowed an indoor visit from march
the 8th
and schools could return around the same
time
many have already adapted to continue
teaching the children of essential
workers throughout the pandemic
students and staff at this london school
have regular tests on the school
premises
and teachers their own boxes of personal
protective equipment
each site has its own problems we have
only one entrance in and out for you
know almost a thousand students
so that kind of creates its own kind of
challenges and having to change
timetables and movements of students
and we've got to think about our local
residents in the same process
and ensuring that things are safe after
the return of schools
the government says allowing people to
have more social contact will be an
absolute priority but the prospect of
foreign travel or summer holidays
seems some way off options being
cautiously considered
include allowing two households to mix
outdoors in the coming weeks
a move many in the capital seem more
than ready to embrace
neave barker al jazeera london